there's more and more push towards
remote work
without i think a deep understanding of
why these meetings are so draining on
people i just anecdotally i've heard
from that but maybe that's because the
managers the people who arrange the
meetings are just not
sufficiently yet aware of the draining
nature of them so that they pull in too
many people they schedule them too
regularly so they need to adjust that
kind of thing probably i think people
are starting to realize but
i i would say one reason that zoom is so
draining is because
you can see your own self presentation
the whole time if you choose to
and
when you go into in person you can't so
you're kind of afraid of thinking about
that
so it's like an extra cognitive load
that you're bearing the whole time
oh yeah and like you might want to you
know turn off the camera so you can't
see yourself but then you feel like well
i have the ability to so i probably
should be doing it and then that alone
is a decision that you're making yeah
there's probably studies on this now
happening either have happened or are
happening
of the effect of seeing your own face
on on camera because it's reminding you
that you're supposed to be acting a
certain way and that's
that is especially a stressful thing
yeah you can't be in the moment as much
but i mean for you you you make the
decision to do all your podcast
interviews in person right
and so and that's
even when it's very costly if there's
any kind of chemistry that contributes
at all
to the conversation which i think most
conversations have chemistry even the
boring work meanings there's something
there
because yes you're trying to solve a
particular problem at this particular
time
but underneath it there's a team
building that's happening and
honestly
people also have told me about this why
they enjoyed the zoom meetings during
uh the pandemic
is like they're lonely yeah yeah like
they
you know it's annoying to have to sit
and listen to folks talk about nothing
and so on but they they tune in anyway
because
it's kind of lonely to sit there by
yourself and that
i mean there's a deep connection there
when you're with other people and that
is especially true when they're you
they're in person which is a huge
concern for me for like more and more
offices
from a capitalist perspective
realizing hey why are we why do we have
these large office spaces why do we have
to get people together but i think in
some in some deep sense we do but then
you also talk about that once we do we
want to protect
the introverts
like you don't want the open
space which office space which was a big
fad for a while i don't know where
people stand on that at this point yeah
i think people are figuring it out in a
post-pandemic context but
i mean i know what you mean
so
before i became a writer i was a
corporate lawyer for like seven years
and
literally the only thing i miss from
those years
is hanging out with
people
at the office like
i don't know just some of the funniest
moments i've had in my life came from
being at the office until midnight with
the other people i was working with so i
know exactly what you're talking about
though i will say the office is there at
that firm and at most firms in those
days everybody had their own office so
it was like a dorm room you know where
it was like a long hallway with
everybody in their own little dorm room
so you had tons of privacy but you would
also come out and
hang out with people
you